hi guys his silver run again and I'm
eating a gingerbread man so now
basically last episode I had some issues
with lag and all that kind of stuff
I got perhaps to work by leading all my
previous fraps video files so um I have
no idea what cost the lag and I'm very
afraid that I will return especially
because I don't even have that much yet
you know with the amount of details I
put into my buildings it's probably
going to crash like soon
MMI PC is going to explode or something
but for now let's let's do some stuff
that's build a ferris wheel I think this
is a good location yeah that's cool I
like that I think it's exactly in the
middle yeah it is okay perfect
now this is one weird place to have an
entrance so I'm having it here if you
don't mind and the exit here now the
collar is kind of suck at the moment I
want to have them similar to the collars
I already have in the rest of my Park mm
mm hmm let's see hmm maybe something
right mm-hmm
not too bad it'll do for now now some
paths let's just quickly create them
nope get out of there this is always
tricky because these paths are invisible
of course now I want to know where I had
my connection so that's over there then
over here it's all what this is new
correct yeah that's right no
I need to use some invisible purse here
as well of course if I can and
connection alright so I know I kind of
know where to put things I need to get
rid of that I don't even manage to do
that
alright that no all right yeah that's
good
now I want to create some sort of
platform and maybe a little temple kind
of thing in the front here and let's see
you know what I could do a small
time-lapse of that
and
hmm I'm been messing around with this
for way too long but I really like the
final look I have right now it's some
kind of Brandenburger tor kind of
structure in front of it I thought at
first I wouldn't put something in front
of it because it's a ferris wheel after
all but mmm I like the general look this
especially the way it's all symmetrical
and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah must have
perfect symmetry so that's pretty cool
and yeah I'm going to do some path work
for this and then see if I can fit a
little coaster building thing into this
episode but I don't exactly think so but
I might just do that huh I'll see but
first I need to do some path work and
that kind of stuff in here in some way
or square or something so let's start a
time-lapse
we can
me
yes
we keep dreaming
all right that's all finished go a
little square-ish thing with a lot of
paths around the ferris wheel because I
had no idea what to do um now I do think
about putting some more planters and
here's some smaller planters with other
stuff and also filling in these planters
a little bit more but that's all in the
end of the game because I want to do the
foliage all the detailed foliage at the
end because it causes a lot of lag and
I'm already kind of lagging so I don't
want that to cause problems so that's
why I'm doing that at a later stage so
for now I declare this Plaza to almost
be finished I'm gonna later on
put some attractions restaurants stuff
and fences around these places but the
core of the plaza and the main layout is
done right now and I kind of like the
look of it with the ferris wheel and all
the flower you've powdery things and mmm
it's not bad so next time I'm going to
do a coaster it's finally going to
happen and either here or here somewhere
I'm getting to build a coaster not sure
what I'm going to do here I just wanted
to have this little river like thing in
the middle but yeah that's all next time
so see you then